[Music]
table tennis is more commonly known as
ping-pong folding table tennis tables
are popular in homes and kept outdoors
because they can be closed up and rolled
out of the way these tables can also
fold down on just one side allowing for
solo play this high-end outdoor table
tennis table has an aluminum bottom that
prevents the tabletop called the plate
from warping or splitting due to
expansion and contraction a press stamps
cups into a sheet of aluminum this
pattern creates nearly equal areas both
in contact and out of contact with the
rest of the plate layers providing
flexibility to withstand temperature
related movement each table needs two
embossed aluminum sheets one for each
half of the plate a technician assembles
frames for the plate halves out of
square extruded aluminum tubes cut to
the lengths and widths of the plate half
perimeter an automated milling machine
makes miter cuts which allow the tubes
to be made into rectangles
then the technician moves the frames
onto a rotating fixture and welds the
corners together
[Music]
[Music]
the frames are inserted into a brushing
machine inside wire brush rollers allow
the aluminum surface to become rough
this helps the components to adhere to
one another another technician places
the embossed aluminum sheet into a
rectangular assembly jig and adds the
brushed aluminum frame a conveyor
transfers the jig to the next station
then the jig connects with an 8
millimeter thick sheet of particleboard
made of wood chips and glue the board is
coated with the heat activated adhesive
film on both sides at the next station
an aluminum sheet is placed on top of
the particle board this step completes
the plate component assembly next the
conveyer loads the jig into a press once
12 jigs have been loaded onto the press
it heats to 239 degrees Fahrenheit and
compresses them for about 10 minutes
this process activates the adhesive and
bonds the components of each plate into
a single unit one framed plate half each
plate half goes through an automated
milling machine
[Music]
the machine trims any excess material
from all four sides to ensure the table
won't have any sharp edges
[Music]
the plate half goes through a paint
machine then into an oven the process
repeats applying a second coat of paint
and a UV resistant clear coat a machine
applies paint through a screen stencil
printing the lines that mark the
boundaries of the playing surface
[Music]
after the paint is dried in an oven a
team places the finished plate half in a
cardboard box and attaches folding legs
to the base the factory Mills the legs
in house out of high tensile steel then
finishes them and baked on paint the net
along with several components are packed
and made in-house which the consumer
later assembles to the table components
include the net posts side panels wheels
wheel brakes and the ball return box
finally the plate half is transferred to
an automated system which completes the
packaging many ping pong tables on the
market require the net to be removed
every time you fold the table the design
of this table enables the net to remain
in place whether the table is folded for
storage or has one or both sides open
for playing less set-up time means more
time to play
[Music]